[Music]  Jonah Hill steps out looking fitter than  ever what do you mean by that exactly  the 33 year old actor was spotted  grabbing a smoothie in Los Angeles on  Friday ahead of his morning workout sesh  looking noticeably slimmer rocking a  navy blue tank that showed off his  ripped arms black workout shorts and  matching socks he paired his athleisure  wear with vans and a silver chain hey  this is not the first time Jonah's  worked on his weight he dramatically  shed the pounds in 2011 and appeared to  gain it back by 2014 we first got a peek  at Jonah's recent slimmed down look at  the Golden Globes in January and again  at the SAG Awards later that month  [Music]  you